could better models eliminate the
predictive disaster and my answer is no
they couldn't you see Roger models are
mathematical systems of equations that
can only predict anything if
solved but to be solved the models need
to assume that which they need to
demonstrate and that is a tendency of
the capitalist economy to some
equilibrium dynamic equilibrium but
equilibrium nevertheless and there's the
r because capitalism from where I'm
standing is a system that is permanently
in disequilibrium and therefore
predictive failures are hardwired into
every economic or Central Bank model and
I think that was a deeper meaning behind
the quip by John Kenneth galb that
econometric was devised as if to make
astrologists look
good